continuing along through the gram of
words this time we're going to focus on
the part of speech known as the verb
will study a variety of properties that
are grammatically marked on verbs in
many languages let's start with person
number and gender number and gender
we've already discussed with nouns and
they work similarly with verbs a verb
might take an ending to represent a
singular number versus a plural number
consider the example in English he talks
versus they talk talks is marked in the
singular and talked is unmarked or may
be marked with a zero morpheme in the
plural the verb is marked for number
class and gender is sometimes marked on
verbs too there are languages like
Hebrew Aramaic and Arabic the Semitic
languages that distinguished gender in
their verb formation person is something
we haven't covered yet grammatical
person actually refers to the distance
of removal from the speaker
so I'm talking to you you're the second
person I'm the first person somebody
else that is neither me nor you will be
the third person but person doesn't
indicate number so if there's a group of
us in other words if it's in the plural
we are the first person you all are the
second person and they are the third
person plural it's not at all uncommon
for languages to mark person
grammatically on the verb in early
modern English speakers said something
like I say thou sayest but he saith and
there the verb ending reflects the
person if you're learning another
indo-european language person number
endings are a common sight let's move on
to tense aspect and mood tense is the
time of the verb it's when the action
takes place so verbs tense might
indicate that it happened in the past
such as I said versus I say it might
indicate that it happens in the future
in English we do this periphrastic lis I
will say rather than a future tense
ending
but the romance languages for example do
have future tense endings so you say da
in Spanish in Italian Deedle in French
da da there's an inflection and it shows
you that the action takes place in the
future it's a future tense
so the basic tenses are past present and
future makes sense
aspect refers not to when the action
takes place but the flow of the action
so if something is done of a specific
point in time if it has a definite start
and ending point its perfective if it
does not have a definite start and
ending point it would be imperfective
and there are a variety of other aspects
we could talk about for example the four
quantitive
English distinguishes these periphrastic
aliy so we have a progressive aspect I
am going versus a perfective or simple
aspect I go these are both present tense
actions so the tense doesn't change but
the aspect does mood to some degree
reflects the speaker's attitude or
judgment about the action taking place
something that is happening would
normally be put in the declarative or
indicative mood those types of moods
that indicate facts or just plain
statements are often known as reales
moods because they reference something
real other moods are often called eariy
alice moods this is just one way of
categorizing moods aerialist moods
include hypothetical moves like the
conditional and other moods that might
be a bit more emotional like the
imperative mood so if I say go that's
the imperative mood but if I just say
you are going that's a declarative it's
a statement of fact
in one case I'm stating something that's
unreal but wished-for and in the other
case something that Israel another mood
you will run into in European languages
is the subjunctive and that's a
counterfactual mood that demonstrates
that the action isn't necessarily the
case so for instance in English we can
say if I worried you
with the subjunctive form of the verb be
we don't say I were outside of that
subjunctive which is because the
counterfactual or hypothetical statement
triggered the use of the subjunctive
mood the same thing would be set in any
Romance language
in many languages questions and
negations are also moves in Japan the
question I am asking can be answered
with the negative edema saying which is
marked with the suffix for the negative
mood another property of verbs is voice
which details the relationship between
the action and those participating in
the action the basic voices of active
and passive active voice includes all of
these samples we've used for verbs so
far if something is done that requires
the passive voice the passive voice in
English is formulated with B and a past
participle but other languages do things
differently you can compare Latin which
actually taxon suffixes to the root to
form a passive so for instance we have
Amal in the active I love but a mode I
am loved in the passive you can compare
that to English
I love versus I am loved where I am
loved is a periphrastic construction as
was the case with nouns we can consider
all the various forms of a verb taking
into account all of the properties that
those forms reflect and in doing so we
conjugate the verb we can list all of
the verbs various forms in a Charter
pick out a specific form based on the
properties that we discussed
that's called a conjugation I hope
you're now comfortable with some of the
basic terms that are used for discussing
the grammar of verbs next time we learn
the basics of pronouns
you